oh my God look I cannot believe it
there's literally thousands of shower
fins drying on the roof of those flats
how the hell do we get up there
[ __ ]
hello hello I talked to you about the
sharp ends up no don't worry about that
okay talk to you about the shark fins
sir
can I go upstairs please can you tell me
upstairs hello hello excuse me
why are you taking them away
smells like petrol just throwing some
ship on the top of the roof over hello
hello
hello
I've got a sneaky suspicion that every
block of flats here look I drawing out
shark fins
then we'll expose because they've got no
cover on them this one here has got a
cover on them and this one here has got
the winches and the ropes inside so
there's one two three four
roofs now they've got the [ __ ] dogs
out
so okay
Akagi black car blacked out windows [ __ ]
you now
okay
gonna get onto one of these roofs they
seem aware that the champagne trade is
controversial I want to see what they're
hiding hello
my gosh
look at this now on top of the roof and
these are all laid out to dry it must be
thousands of them here fans on the top
almost like their air drying a great to
make the most amazing wine it's a sharp
four in graveyard with fins for sale in
the shops for up to 200 pounds each the
amount of money on this one roof alone
is mind-boggling it's a goldmine my god
this is incredible is every roof like
this this place is a [ __ ] joke okay
she just caught them on the telephone
let's get the [ __ ] out of here we're
going we're going yeah yeah we're going
unbelievable
[ __ ] me let's get out of here before we
get shot